[Music]
so
[Music]
coming up on fyi are the devastating
floods and droughts across the world
down to climate change
[Music]
and why amora was becoming vegan and is
it better for the planet i became vegan
because i knew the impact it has on the
animals as well as the impact in the
environment
[Music]
this is fyi your weekly news show where
we bring you the latest on the big
stories in the uk and around the world
yeah and we've got loads of info for you
this week but first we love nothing more
than to investigate possible fake news
and put your fake news detection skills
to the test so let's see what you think
[Music]
now this is a pretty out of this world
story apparently an eight-year-old girl
managed to radio call the international
space station from her own home and
actually speak to an astronaut but is
this recording real
mike zero lima
my name is isabella i'm eight years old
this is na1ss welcome to the
international space station
oh how about this photo being shared
online of a peninsula which is known as
bear mountain because it looks like a
bear but does it really look like that
or is it just photo editing fake news or
fact we'll let you know later
so scarlet have you been seeing these
devastating floods that have been hit in
pakistan and apparently a third of the
country is covered by water and sadly
many people have died that's so awful i
know it is and this is all down to heavy
rainfall during what's known as their
monsoon season which obviously means as
you can see it rains all the time but
this happens every year in pakistan but
they're saying this could be the worst
they've ever seen rivers have been
bursting their banks and countries like
the uk and others have been supplying
aid and support but they still think
that more is needed so from floods to
droughts i mean most of europe and even
some parts of the uk as we've seen have
been experiencing a drought from all
these heatwaves we've been getting and
the very little rainfall and apparently
it's the worst drought in over 500 years
and experts are even warning that this
could affect the amount of food we get
from crops this year i mean it's crazy
in it and check this out in china so
they've been experiencing their hottest
and dry summer on record so they've been
sending rockets and drones up into the
clouds to try and bring on rain how does
that work i know it sounds made up on it
so it's a process called cloud seeding
basically the aircraft sprays a special
chemical into the clouds which makes the
water droplets in the clouds cluster
together and increases the chances of
rain
experts are warning us that heat waves
and floods will be more common if we
don't stop polluting our atmosphere with
gases that lead to climate change so we
know that loads of you really care about
stopping climate change and we'd love to
hear about how you're doing your bit to
help yeah we heard from fyi news club
member liberty who wanted to tell us all
about why she chooses to be vegan and
why that helps the planet she also got
her friend pippa involved over to you
liberty
[Music]
hey i'm liberty i'm 11 years old and i'm
a vegan that means i don't eat meat fish
eggs any dairy product
hi i'm pippa and i'm an omnivore which
means i can eat fish meat vegetables and
animal products today i'm here with my
friend pippa at the jasmine show i
wanted to show pippa why i choose to be
vegan and this show has loads of vegan
food on offer let's go check it out
[Music]
i'm really looking forward to see the
chocolate stands the marshmallow stands
and the vegan meat substitutes and
cheese substitutes i've not already
tried much vegan food before so this is
going to be something new for me
everyone else in my family also eats
meat which kind of means that if i
didn't eat meat i'd have to have
separate meals if i were to go vegan i'd
probably miss eggs because it's part of
everyday life like eating cakes and
things like that
people think that going vegan means less
choice but that's not true you can make
practically anything so good one of the
things i love is pasta bottle grenades
and that's got beef in it which is
obviously meat the good news peppa is
that there's even vegan spaghetti
bolognese you've just replaced the beef
with lentils or a meat substitute and
lots of vegetables
broccoli
but quite crispy broccoli uh-huh that is
tasty because i can't stand the texture
of broccoli i became vegan when i was
like eight and then before that i was on
enough vegetarian because i knew the
impact it has on the animals as well as
the impact in the environment i've heard
that the global meat industry accounts
for over 14.5 percent of global
greenhouse emissions the majority of the
stuff is really tasty and peppa
definitely likes some of the stuff too
you've even got spreadable cheese oh
yeah we must try
the cheese was not very nice it was
just nice i didn't really like it very
much at all i thought there's no way
this is going to be making me vegan or
any or veggie or anything like that and
i went in i tried some of the food and
actually thought wow this is actually
way nicer than what i normally eat
[Music]
thanks liberty and pippa so scarlett
what do you reckon would you go vegan i
think there are loads of positives to it
but for me i think i'd miss eating meat
too much
and if there's something you'd like to
report on on fyi then the best way is to
join the fyi news club we love it when
you get in touch with us so check out
the details on our webpage first dot
news fyi and you could be on screen
before you know it so as a lot of us
head back to school you might be
wondering whether coronavirus will
affect us this term or whether it's all
behind us well some scientists are
worried that us thinking coverts over
means we won't be getting vaccinated or
get the booster vaccine this autumn and
they think that getting vaccinated is
the best way we'll manage covert going
forward but how do vaccines work don't
get it mai's been investigating
[Music]
coronavirus
it's a thousand times smaller than the
width of an eyelash but this tiny bug
has caused a giant problem
millions of people have died from it and
many more have had to be treated in
hospital
even though most children don't get
seriously ill from it there's no doubt
it's had an impact on all of us
it was originally noticed in the chinese
city of rouhan but after just a few
months it spread all over the world
becoming a pandemic
now though thanks to some brilliant
scientists we're fighting back
as we all know by now they've come up
with a special kind of medicine called
the vaccine which helps us to protect
ourselves
but to understand more about how
vaccines work we're going to need to use
our time machine
and we're heading back nearly 700 years
[Music]
the year is 1348
we're in london
and the city is going through the worst
pandemic in history they call it the
bubonic plague or the black death and
the smell was awful
the disease was spread by fleas carried
on the fur of rats
[Music]
and like many pandemics it kept on
coming back over the centuries
including the great plague of london in
1665.
another terrible disease that killed
millions of people over many centuries
was smallpox
and that's where vaccines have been an
incredible success story back in 1980
the world health organization declared
that smallpox had been completely wiped
out
it was all thanks to a vaccine developed
by a brilliant british scientist called
edward jenner
with the help of a cow called blossom
jenna took a small sample of a less
serious disease called cowpox and
injected it into an eight-year-old boy
called james phipps
it gave james a mild illness but it also
helps his body to create substances
called antibodies in his blood to fight
off the cow puffs
the clever thing is that these
antibodies also protected james from
catching the similar but more deadly
smallpox disease
the vaccines that have been developed
for covid work in a similar way helping
our bodies to recognize coronavirus
infections and fight them off
but some people have refused to get
vaccinated because they're concerned
about whether or not they're safe
to find out more i'm joined by dr ellie
cannon from the nhs
hi dr ellie hi there so how effective
are covered vaccinations in fighting the
pandemic well thankfully we can see that
they are really effective people who are
vaccinated are much less likely to get
severely ill or
to end up in hospital so we know that
they are incredibly effective
i know some people have been worried
about the safety of the vaccine and the
potential side effects
are they right to be concerned
thankfully with the covered vaccines
once we started giving them to millions
of people globally we could see that the
side effects were actually minimal so
people might have a sore arm or they
might have a temperature for 24 hours
but in fact there were very few side
effects and given the huge benefits for
around the world i think most people
would agree that those small side
effects were worth it
so will the vaccine help us to get rid
of coronavirus altogether like we did
with smallpox
smallpox is quite a different type of
disease in the way it's transmitted and
in how infectious it is in fact covid19
is something called a coronavirus which
you'll all know and we've had
coronaviruses
around for a long time this was just a
new one and we're used to them they
cause coughs and colds and sore throats
and what i think will happen eventually
is covid19 will be just one of those
viruses that we deal with every winter
and we really don't think too much about
it
thank you for your time dr ellie
thank you
so it sounds like coronavirus is going
to be with us for some time to come
but with the help of the vaccine the
hope is that we could soon be returning
to our normal lives
for more i don't get it explainers
within for one loads of different topics
head to sky kids on demand or our
webpage
slash fyi
[Music]
okay braden i've got a question for you
have you ever wanted to time travel and
see what the streets in your hometown
look like years ago i mean it's not
something i've really thought about but
i suppose that'll be awesome wouldn't it
yeah well i got to do just that an event
called story trails has been touring the
country and it's all about discovering
your city's old stories with the help of
some virtual reality i went to check it
out
[Music]
move over doctor who i've come to
lincoln to travel through time and space
and i don't have a tardis all i need is
this and this
this journey through time and space is
called story trails and it's happening
in 15 cities across the uk
the idea is to use the latest tech and
archive footage to learn about the
history of your city in lincoln for
example the augmented reality or ar
trail invites visitors to meet the
city's famous imp who legend has it was
turned to stone by an angel the ar trail
uses an app to tell you about the
history of lincoln it overlays an imp
over real life to tell you a story the
ar basically takes you back in time and
you can see what the city wants look
like and interact with characters from
history thanks for that i thought i'd be
stuck up there forever what was your
favorite part of the day you're in that
world you're in a completely different
place and i feel like sometimes it's way
more fun than the actual world i think
this is a really good way to learn
history i really really liked it i think
it's not like the history at school is
not good it's like
i think it's just more fun there's even
vr headsets to see how life was
different back in the day i'm about to
go back in time using these vr headsets
and be in a 13 year old girl's living
room
it looks very different than a living
room nowadays there's a tv playing
and the tv looks very old there's a
picture of the queen and then a little
tiny clock
there's a carpet oh guitar
i'm playing the guitar
i can hear the guitar
[Music]
this is really cool it's just like a
whole new way to learn and you you feel
like you're learning because you're
learning loads of new information but
then at the same time it's fun and i
think this type of learning and lots of
people like it stays in their brain
better and they remember it for longer
although the tour may already have left
town you can still experience story
trails in the town libraries as well as
the ar experience on your phone
i think it makes you remember how
quickly life passes by and who knows
one day in the future someone may be
looking at us through a new piece of
technology
[Music]
so did you guess this week's fake news
or fact
the peninsula known as bear mountain
isn't shaped like a bear quite so much
this photo is edited so it's faint news
here's the original photo of what bear
mountain actually looks like
which means this recording of
eight-year-old isabella speaking to an
astronaut on the international space
station is factory
mike zero lima mike kilo this is na1ss
welcome to the international space
station my name is isabella i'm eight
years old
it's so great to chat with you thank you
for getting on the radio and saying
hello
thank you
it's my face
using her dad's radio equipment isabella
managed to radio call the international
space station and she spoke to the
american astronaut chelle lindgren
he posted online that he loved speaking
to radio operators all over the world
but his chat with isabella was his
favorite so far
[Music]
nice one isabella now that's about it
for more but we're going to leave you
with a story that's a little bit closer
to her we want to say a big
congratulations to mac rutherford who at
17 years old has become the youngest
person to ever fly around the world solo
he is following in the footsteps of his
older sister zara who earlier this year
became the youngest woman to fly around
the world solo pretty impressive family
here's more from mac's five-month
journey around the world see you next
time
[Music]
you